(hip hop music)
- I wanted to ask you
what advice you maybe have
for entrepreneurs that are
just about a year and a half
into their journey, but I
feel like everything you
just said is perfect, just
believing in yourself,
having faith, just grinding
out, doing the work,
and eventually success will come.
Is there anything else
that you want to add?
- Yeah I wouldn't, like I
would stop comparing yourself,
like who cares if you're
a year and a half in.
Maybe you're 10 years in, you know?
Like just, if you like what you're doing,
you have a passion for
it, you have to find
a way to keep going.
- [Victor] Absolutely.
- And what I'm looking,
so like I'll look up
to people right, lik I'm
not the greatest speaker
in the world, you know, I love Les Brown.
Either of you guys know Les Brown?
- I know who Les Brown is.
- [Victor] Yes.
- Like young Les Brown,
that guy is sick man.
- [Neil] He's like the...
- I want to be young Les Brown.
(group laughs)
Stuff like Young Les Brown
speaking videos, it's crazy.
I'm nowhere close to young
Les Brown, but I'm not like,
so what like, so what that I'm not close,
like it's an aspiration to me.
Like people chase perfection,
and they get pissed
when they don't hit their goal.
It's not about the goal, it's about
doing the work to get better.
And I think just continually,
like hard work is just,
I guess in me.
When I talked about my agent.
When I joined the agency, I was
the worst one at the agency.
Like my agent Steve
was like you know what,
I don't know if I want to take you on man.
I don't know if I want
you as a client like.
Everybody else who had been
with him, they were more
polished speakers than
I was, and I understand.
I look back at my videos like
I actually really sucked.
I thought I was hot stuff,
but I really sucked.
And then, he said, but you
know okay we'll take a flier,
like you're our flier for the
year, we'll see what happens.
And then, I just worked
harder than everybody else.
When they were having a
hard time, like he asked
me to do my story.
One of the first
exercises, make your story.
So I would make a video about my story
like 15 minute video.
He would review it, I'd
make it in the morning,
he would review it, give me feedback.
Afternoon I'd do it
again, another 15 minutes,
right he'd review it,
he'd give me feedback,
and do it again at night
like, three, four times a day,
if he's making it.
I did that intro story 40 times for him.
- [Neil] Wow.
- And he gave me feedback.
I would make videos every
day when the other people
at the agency complained
about not having time
during the week to make one video.
- Absolutely.
- And so, I, within a
couple months, I became the
best-practiced example.
They're like you guys should
be doing what Evan's doing.
I was the worst one!
(group laughs)
I was the worst!
I had no talent, no skill.
I just listened to their advice,
and grinded, and I became
the best-practiced.
So it's like, it's not for me to say
I'm a genius or I'm special.
Like it's the opposite, I'm not special.
I'm super ordinary, introverted,
don't have the skills,
and I just worked hard.
I've done 4,000 videos
on my YouTube channel.
Some of them are, are unlisted,
they're like practice videos.
There're like 4,000, you better get better
if you take 4,000 shots, right?
Like you have to be a new
level of garbage to not improve
after trying something 4,000 times, right?
So, I think people put too
much pressure on themselves
to be good at the start.
You see, maybe you see a
Gary V, or you see somebody
like crushing it hard, and
you go out and try to do it,
and your thing sucks like,
you suck at the start.
And the hard part is, you have taste,
but you don't have the skill.
Like you know what's good.
You know what a good jump shot looks like,
but you can't do it, and
so when you get out there
and you know that you suck, you quit.
And so whatever you're making,
you know what will look good.
You have certain standards
for quality, and then when
you can't go out and make
that immediately, you quit.
And so, it's good to have those standards.
It's good to have like
the MJ jump shot as the
thing to aspire to, but
understand that you're
going to suck, you're going to fall.
You're not going to get
anything the first time,
and just make everything
better, everything better.
Like, maybe you guys look
at your show and like,
hey we love The Breakfast Club, you know.
(both laugh)
One of you is going to be
Charlamagne and one you know like.
- Oh, goodness gracious.
- It's a good show man,
like I was there at...
- I feel like Charlamagne
is my spirit animal, Evan.
I'm not going to lie.
- Right so like, okay, it's
a good show to model right.
So Breakfast Club awesome,
have guests come in, great.
But, it takes time to be that good, right.
They put a ton of practice
in, and so, it's like
that's the ideal, and here's
where we are and just,
every show needs to be
better like, whoever you
bring on next, that show has to be better
than that Evan Carmichael show.
Let's see it, and you just
keep building your way up,
and you get to be at a higher level so,
I think it's hard when people
see that they don't have,
they know what looks good
and they can't do it,
and they just quit too soon.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Thank you to the guys from VNR Media
for the awesome interview.
The full link is in the description below
if you want to check it out.
I love to know, what did you think?
What are your thoughts?
Leave them in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout-out to Kamil Kubiak.
Thank you so much Kamil for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.